let's go next to our caller from the
9:03 area code who's calling today from
9:03 my name is Vince hey Vince what's
up
um do pregnant women get $500 from the
recovery package I can't imagine that
they do you cannot or you can I cannot
imagine that they do know but then the
Republicans would have to use a reason
for that right right yeah well I over I
guess it's not a person right all right
you denied them the $500 you have to
admit that they're not full-blown kids
yeah no that's I've not heard that
raised before and it's an interesting
one and I wonder what Republicans would
say I mean certainly some of them would
probably say well by the time that kids
born all of this is going to be resolved
and of course a lot of those kids are
going to be born next week and that's
obviously not going to be the case but
that is interesting I wonder what they
would say if pressed on that and what do
you think about how Biden just picked
Obama has his running mate I did not
hear that
April Fool's gotcha all right thank you
so much Vince very much appreciate the
call all right take care
yeah you didn't get me with that one you
didn't get me with that one let's go
next to our caller from the 949 area
code who is calling today from 949 hey
this is Kenny calling from 9 for 9 yeah
Kenny what's going on hey so I actually
have a question that's not relate to
this whole coronavirus things you know
just about governing in general I think
one of the things that comes it's how we
do a lot of our institutional loans and
rules that used to govern us to the past
like one example is how we only govern
for three days of the week appliances
will be kinda missing which is before
the court reading back some of the
institutions and norms of the Congress
that we used to have such as that
you know Kenny your connection was so
garbled were you asking whether we
should bring back some of these
conventions uh yeah I mean it depends on
which one you know the entire thing
about governing on three days instead of
five there's arguments that you want our
elected officials spending more time in
their districts with their constituents
rather than in Washington DC you know I
can sort of see both sides of that I
don't know that there's any one kind of
simple answer to that question
unfortunately right it's just that there
was a recent vice interview that was
aired a couple of months ago about how
some of the former congressman drawn-out
leaving yeah that suggested that this is
actually a very big problem because it
doesn't allow them to form a working
whether slative relationship with their
other fellow congressmen because quite
frankly people spend more time out of
Washington they spend in Washington so
as a result nothing ever happened in
Washington yeah I mean maybe the happy
medium would be that they're doing four
days a week instead of three but not
five like I don't you know we're kind of
really slicing and dicing things here
but there's no doubt that you know we
would the question that really needs to
be asked is would more bills get passed
if they spent an extra day there or
would there just be more debate and more
filibustering but the same amount gets
done and if more bills are passed is
that objectively good maybe some of the
bills that would get passed aren't
things that we want so I just think that
there's more the devil is really in the
details there right it's just one of the
consequences I've said being less in
Washington is that people are
campaigning for yes one of the problems
that we often hear is about the problem
of money in politics as well as people
constantly campaigning right there's no
money has more power and people are
suggested maybe beyond sort of the
campaign season well it turns out I
think that by restoring some of our
congressional scheduling the way we used
to have it like we did before the
nineties that mean one deal to
inadvertently fix this problem of having
too much money in politics people are
campaigning to watching
Kenny you're fading out so I'm gonna let
you go your connection is is abhorrent
unfortunately but that's the best
possible argument I could imagine for
spending more time in DC which is just
keep people off the campaign trail I
would love to see that combined with
public financing of Elections as well
and a date certain before which you
cannot start campaigning like maybe you
know limit the full campaign to six
months where you have you know three
months for the primary campaigning and
then the final three months leading up
to the vote or something like that
because all too far too much time is
spent campaigning especially with
two-year terms in the House of
Representatives you essentially start
campaigning a few months after you're
sworn in and it is a major major waste
of time and the American people suffer
as a result